there's drafting something we know about
in NASCAR and other very fast races but
there's also drafting and cycling it's
crucial inside thing in Tour de France
so somebody in front of you you can get
an advantage from that you certainly
can't the energy you need to expend
reduces up by maybe 30% so I asked Lance
about that let's see what he says about
drafting so let's talk about drafting
okay so one of the most important parts
of this so presumably there's some speed
below which drafting is not useful right
that would be like one mile and or
anything more than anything more than
stationary keep in mind that the the
speed is important to talk about but the
wind is if you if if you say 10 miles an
hour that's not very fast but if the
wind is 50 miles an hour in your face 10
miles an hour is pretty fast so your
draft it's just it goes up exponentially
the more intense the wind is the
direction of the wind right obviously if
it's right in front of you you stay
right behind the rider and that's in
front of you if the wind is from the
left then you inch over to the right
okay so you just find it's very so I say
NASCAR you find that sweet spot of where
that draft is right and that's and then
of course that just gets multiplied if
there's one rider in front of you you
have a draft if there are a hundred
riders in front of you you're not even
pedaling so max this first this sounds
like it sounds lazy first of all yeah
and diabolical is you exploiting the
energy of the leader yeah so then why
does anyone leave the race because
that's their job because their team
leader may be behind them so they may be
a domestique one of these servants to go
at the front to take the brunt of the
wind so the people behind their team
leader can save their energy by
slipstreaming now what if what if those
servant wins
that's good that doesn't happen Scott
that doesn't happen and no one's ever
gone rogue people go rogue on one day
but the next day suddenly they find they
don't get out of the caravan
[Music]